ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM IN A
**** BATH BONTA BRO BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAO GEN DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN
CHU COOLEY COOPER. CUNNINGHAM
DALLY DAILY DE EGGMAN FLORA
FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY. LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI DOES.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WORD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN REVEREND COUNTY OR
STAFF. MEMBER NISHA. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. SUPER BOWL IS ONE
OF THE BIGGEST SPORTING EVENTS
OF THE YEAR AND NOW SUPER BOWL
FIFTY FOUR IS HISTORY. HI WITH
THE KANSAS CITY CHIEFS COMING
FROM BEHIND TO WIN IN THE
FOURTH QUARTER IT WAS A TRULY
EXCITING GAME. BUT ULTIMATELY
IN THE BIG PICTURE OF THINGS
THE MEANING OF LIFE IS NOT
ABOUT WINNING OR LOSING THE
GAME. NOR IS IT ABOUT GETTING
WHAT WE WANT OR HAVING OR WAY.
WITH MY WISDOM EYES OPEN I KNOW
THAT WHAT HAS ALWAYS GIVEN
MEANING TO MY LIFE. IS TO FEEL
THAT I DID MY BEST TO LIVE
CHERISHING EACH DAY
APPRECIATING THE PEOPLE IN MY
LIFE. WE'RE WITH THEM EYES OPEN
LET US TRY TO LIVE FEELING THE
FRESHNESS OF EACH NEW DAY. AND
I DON'T SEE THAT IN THE BIG
PICTURE OF THINGS THE MEANING
OF LIFE IS NOT ABOUT WINNING OR
LOSING. IT IS BEING ABLE TO
LOOK BACK AND FEEL THAT WE DID
OUR VERY BEST TO LIVE GRATEFUL
FOR IT EACH NEW DAY. NUMBER ONE
WE DON'T SEE WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS. THANK
YOU REVEREND OUR STAFF WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE. MEMBERS
IN I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. THERE WAS. YEAH. THANK
YOU YOU MAY BE. READ OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
SACRAMENTO FRIDAY DURING
SEVENTY TWENTY TWO SOME IT NOT
A AND WE ARE WILL RECORD HAD
IT'S JUST AS WE WHATEVER THESE
ALL OWN MOVES IN THIS GIBSON.
THE READING OF THE DAY'S
JOURNAL BE TO WITH.
PRESENTATIONS IMAGES THERE ARE
NONE INTERNET REFERENCE A BILL
WILL BE TO. REPORTS OF. WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ARE ABSENCES TODAY
FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS KALRA INCOMING
HIM. FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GRAY MAIENSCHEIN AND
WALDRON AND FOR MATERNITY LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER ALSO REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO. SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE ALLOWS ONLY MEMBERS IRWIN
KILEY LOW MOAN MATHIS AND WOULD
TO SPEAK ON IN GERMANY MEMORY
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO STRIKE
ITEM NUMBER TO AB SEVEN TEN
CERVANTES FROM THE FILE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY WE
ARE TWO FORMER MEMBERS OF THE
BODY FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HELEN THOMPSON. AND FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS WILL OCCUR
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
PLEASE WELCOME THEM.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO RECOGNIZE FEBRUARY
THIRD THROUGH SEVEN AS NATIONAL
SCHOOL COUNSELING WEEK.
NATIONAL SCHOOL COUNSELING WEEK
HIGHLIGHTS THE INCREDIBLE
IMPACT THAT SCHOOL COUNSELORS
HAVE BEEN HELPING STUDENTS
ACHIEVE SCHOOL SUCCESS AND
PLANNING AHEAD. TODAY IS MY
HONOR TO INTRODUCE TO YOU THE
TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA
COUNSELOR OF THE YEAR SERWIS
LEMONS OF CULVER MIDDLE SCHOOL
INCULVER CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. SIR IS- UP UP IN THE
UP ABOVE SHE SAID ACCOMPANIED
BY ASHLEY KRUGER PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL COUNSELORS AND AMY.
MAGNET IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL COUNSELORS SERVE
RECEIVED A BACHELOR OF ARTS
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF REDLANDS
AND MASTERS OF OUR HEARTS AND
COUNSELING AND PEOPLE PERSONAL
SERVICES CREDENTIAL. CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY DOMINGUEZ
HILLS SIERRA HAS REMARKABLE
LEADERSHIP SKILLS. A NATURAL
TALENT FOR COUNSELING AND
INSINCERE INTEREST AND THE BEST
OUTCOMES FOR HER STUDENTS SERRA
HAS DEVOTED HER CAREER TO
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AND ADDRESSING THEIR
ACADEMIC AND SOCIAL. SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
COLLEGE READINESS SHE HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN IMPLEMENTING A
DATA DRIVEN SCHOOL COUNSELING
PROGRAM AT OUR SCHOOL SITE AND
IN ADVOCATING FOR THE PROGRAM
OF THE SCHOOL BOARD. OTHER
SCHOOL COUNSELORS WITHIN HER
DISTRICT IN THE GREATER LOS
ANGELES AREA HER ADVOCACY AS
BENEFIT HER SCHOOL. AND IS
BRANCHED OUT INTO NEARBY DRESS
SIX WHERE SHE CREATED AND
HOSTED THE FIRST ANNUAL MIDDLE
SCHOOL COUNSELOR SYMPOSIUM ON
THE WEST SIDE OF LOS ANGELES.
AS THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
COUNSELOR OF THE YEAR SEVERAL
BE ELIGIBLE TO COMPETE FOR THE
NATIONAL SCHOOL COUNSELOR OF
THE YEAR MEMBERS IT IS MY HONOR
TO SHARE WITH YOU IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SERVICE LEMONS
THE TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA.
SCHOOL COUNSELOR OF THE YEAR.
WELCOME MISS COME LONGER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I TOO AM HONORED TO
RECOGNIZE TERRACE LEMONS OF
CULVER CITY FOR HER RECEIPT. OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL COUNSELORS TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
COUNSELOR OF THE YEAR AWARD SHE
WILL BE THE EIGHTEENTH
COUNSELOR AND THE FIRST ONE
FROM CULVER CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO RECEIVE THE AWARD
SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN TWO
THOUSAND AND- SARAH HAS SPENT
THE PAST FIVE YEARS AT CULVER
CITY MIDDLE SCHOOL IN THE HEART
OF THE FIFTY FOURTH. WHERE SHE
IS NOT ONLY A DISTINGUISHED
STAFF MEMBER BUT TO BE LOVED
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY AS
WELL. SERRA EMBODIES THESE
VALUES. OF HARD WORK
DETERMINATION AND USING OUR
TALENTS TO LIVE OUR LIVES IN
SERVICE TO OTHERS. TO ADVANCE
OUR STUDENTS IN THE CLASSROOM
AND BEYOND THANK YOU SARAH FOR
ALL THAT YOU DO AND FOR ALL
THAT YOU GIVE YOUR STUDENTS OUR
COMMUNITY AND THE FIFTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT ARE MADE
BETTER FOR IT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISS COMMA VERY WELCOMING
GRADUATIONS.
MR TING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IT'S REALLY A MY HONOR
AND IT'S VERY SOUND HONOR- BUT
TO WELCOME AMANDA WILCOX FOR
THOSE OF US WHO WORK IN A
PUBLIC SAFETY ESPECIALLY ON GUN
ISSUES SHE'S BEEN A VOLUNTEER
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE ON FOR THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN SHE'S DONE
REALLY THIS INCREDIBLE JOB BOB.
OF CARRY ON HER DOT LEGACY-
EARLY THROUGH LAURA'S LAW BY
THE LAW SHE WOULD FIRST PASSED
DUE TO THE UNTIMELY DEATH OF
HER DAUGHTER- WE ARE SO
THANKFUL FOR ALL THE HOURS THAT
SHE HAS VOLUNTARILY. GIVEN TO
OUR STATE REALLY TO OUR
COUNTRY- WERE VERY SAD TO SEE
HER GO WELL I KNOW A NUMBER OF
MEMBERS ARE HERE TO ALSO JUST
THINK THAT'S- SENATOR SKINNER
AS WELL AS MY COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS JONES SAWYER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STOP. SO THANK
FOR ALL THE AND MAYES WORKS
LIKE THIS LIKE. WITH SOMEONE
BALLING LEAVES A VOLUNTEER JOB
NOT QUITE SURE WHAT WHAT THAT
MEANS BUT IT MEANS THAT
UNFORTUNATE WE WILL BE SEEING
HER A WHOLE LOT LESS HERE.
CAPITAL BUT JUST WANTED TO JUST
INCREDIBLY- THANK HER FOR THE
BOTTOM OF MY HEART. FOR ALL OF
HER TIRELESS HOURS ADVOCACY ALL
THE WORK AWAY FROM HER FAMILY-
THAT IS PUT INTO LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS- TO POLICY DEBATES
REALLY SHE IS- IF YOU'RE A
PUBLIC SAFE COMMITTEE SHE IS A
VOICE THAT IS ALWAYS THERE. AND
IT WE ARE SO THANKFUL PLEASE
ARM. YOUR BRING WARM UP AND
THEY JUST TAKE A MAN WALKER IN
HER RETIREMENT ALSO FOR ALL HER
OF RIGHT SOURCE.
THANK YOU
MISTER KING MISTER WERE. YES
THANK YOU MATT IS I DO WANT TO
SAY WHAT MY CALL FROM SAN
FRANCISCO SAID ABOUT AMANDA AND
NICK WILCOX. YOU KNOW YOU SEE A
LOT OF PEOPLE HERE WORKING THE
HALLS ON. THE ISSUE THE DAY AND
THEY'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS AND PAINT
AND DOING A TREMENDOUS JOB. AND
OF COURSE WE ALL KNOW ABOUT
LAURA'S LAW THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND THIS LITERALLY
IS- THEIR WORK AFTER THE TRAGIC
LOSS OF THEIR DAUGHTER. I MET
THEM WHEN I WAS A YOUNG CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER AND THEY
PROPOSED TO LAWS AT THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO. AND HAD THE HONOR
OF WORKING WITH THEM AND
CERTAINLY MY PLEASURE TO SEE
THEM HERE TODAY AND WISH THEM
WELL IN THE NEXT CHAPTER THEIR
LIVES THANK YOU.
MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING FILE ITEM ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ. RESOLUTION
ONE FIFTY SIX WITH MINUTES. ALL
BILLS SEVENTEEN DREADED AMEND
TO. FILE ITEMS ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEM THREE
TO FIVE OUR CONTINUED. PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM SIX MOVING
TO FILE ITEM SEVEN SB TWO OH
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL TWO OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR D'AMATO ND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO ELECTIONS CLEARLY
ZERO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
THIS. THIS CAN SALAS YOU ARE A-
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES WE'VE HEARD A LOT
THE NEWS LATELY ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO. MIGHT THINK THEY'RE ONE
PARTY BUT REGISTERED ANOTHER
REGISTER NO PARTY PREFERENCE WE
ALSO KNOW THAT SOMETIMES
PEOPLE- ESPECIALLY PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN APARTMENTS MOVE BEFORE
ELECTION DAY AND YET TODAY THE
WAY THE BILL THE LAW IS WRITTEN
IF THOSETHINGS HAVE HAPPENED
AND YOU GO TO THE POLLS ON
ELECTION DAY YOU HAVE TO CAST A
PROVISIONAL BALLOT. WHAT THIS
BILL WILL DO WILL ALLOW YOU TO
ATTEST TO CHANGES SUCH AS
MOVING WITHIN A COUNTY OR A
CHANGE OF A POLITICAL PARTY
PREFERENCE ON THE DAY OF THE
ELECTION AT A POLLING PLACE AND
ALLOW YOU CAST A TRADITIONAL
BALLOT. THIS WILL ENSURE THAT
OUR BALLOTS ARE COUNTED IN A
MORE TIMELY MANNER ANYBODY THAT
WATCH WHAT HAPPENED LAST LIKE
XIN CYCLE AS THAT THINGS BACKED
UP IN THE NUMBER PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS BACKED UP IT WAS A GOOD
FOR ANYONE. ALTHOUGH I'M THE
REPUBLICANS HAVEN'T OPPOSE ON
THIS POSITION I WOULD KNOW THAT
IT IS IN FACT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY THAT REQUIRES PEOPLE TO
REGISTER IS REPUBLICAN IN ORDER
TO CAST THEIR BALLOTS SO IT IN
FACT HELPED OUR OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE REPUBLICAN
PRIMARY I DURING THE SELECTION
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE. IN YOU MISS OUT.
MR KILEY WERE. THINK ABOUT AS
BIG I I'M IN SOME OF BILL I
THINK THAT CONCERN THE BEEN RAY
ABOUT VOTER FRAUD ARE NOT A
SERIOUS IN THIS IS A SO OTHERS
I THINK ANY ELECTION OFFICE I
CAN EASILY AVOID DOUBLE
COUNTING VOTES BY SIMPLY
INVALIDATING ANY ABSENTEE
BALLOT THAT COMES IN FOR
SOMEONE WHO IS ALREADY VOTED ON
ELECTION DAY THE BENEFIT SEE TO
THIS BATTLE IS IT SOME MINOR
IMPROVEMENTS A PROBLEM IN OUR
STATE THAT I BELIEVE HAS BECOME
QUITE SEVERE AND THAT'S THE
PROTRACTED. NATURE BOTH OF
BEING AN ACCOUNT EACH OF WHICH
ALLOW THIRTY DAYS BEFORE AND
AFTER ELECTION DAY IN
CALIFORNIA I BECOME
INCREASINGLY CONCERNED THAT
THIS RAISES SERIOUS ISSUES
AROUND DEMOCRATIC LEGITIMACY I
JUST LOOK MOST DRAMATIC EXAMPLE
OF THE ON GOING ENSURE BASE WE
HAVE SOME VOTING START THIS
WEEK. TO CONTINUE VOTE IN UP
AND EARLY PART ABOUT THAT GOING
TO HAVE. IN THAT TIMES FOR YOUR
HAVE CANNOT DROP OUT OF THE
RIGHT. SO PEOPLE WILL BE. IN
LITERALLY DE ELECTIONS YET
THOUGH JUST BE ONE SINGLE TALLY
ALTHOUGH THAT TALLY WILL NOT BE
FINALIZED UNTIL WEEKS AFTER
ELECTION DAY EVEN THOUGH ON
ELECTION NIGHT YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE SOME REPORTING AS TO WHO'S
AHEAD. AND THAT MAY WELL BE
DIFFERENT THAN THE PERSON WHO
ULTIMATELY HAS A LEAD ONCE ALL
THE BALLOTS HAVE BEEN COUNTED
WE DON'T KNOW IN PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARIES THINGS LIKE MOMENTUM
AND NARRATIVES OFTEN MATTER
MORE THAN THE ACTUAL
ASSIGNMENTS. OF DELEGATES SO
ARE VOTE COUNTING SYSTEM
CREATES THIS POTENTIAL TO SORT
OF SKEW ELECTION OUTCOMES-
THROUGH FALSE NARRATIVES AND
FALSE MOMENTUM SO I THINK THIS
BILL WILL HELP A LITTLE BIT. BY
ALLOWING MORE PEOPLE TO VOTE ON
ELECTION DAY AND ASSURING THOSE
BALLOTS ARE COUNTED ON THAT DAY
RATHER THAN SET ASIDE AS
PROVISIONALS ALTHOUGH I THINK
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO ON
WINE. THE MASS ARE ELECTIONS
CODE HAS MADE AND MOVED BACK
TOWARDS THE DEMOCRATIC IDEAL OF
ELECTIONS. I OUT ONCE AND OUR
THE RESULT BEING RUDE RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
KILEY SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISSING DOLLARS YOU MAY CLOSE.
I JUST CLOSE MY ST ANYTIME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY AND I CAN
AGREE ON A BILL YOU SHOULD
DEFINITELY VOTE I. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THAT YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
SQUIRES FIFTY FOUR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. THE WHERE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE HOW YOU
EYES FIFTY NINE KNOWS ELEVEN ON
THE URGENCY ICE FIFTY NINE
ELEVEN ON THE BILL MEASURE
PASSES WITH IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE.
MOVING TO AND NOW. MEMBERS ON
TUESDAY FEBRUARY FOURTH AND
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY FIFTH THE
SPEAKER IS HOSTING A POLICY
SUMMIT ENTITLED RISING TIDE A
SUMMIT ON ECONOMIC SECURITY.
MEMBERS STAFF IN THE PUBLIC ARE
INVITED TO ATTEND THE SUMMIT
WHICH WILL TAKE PLACE THE
ASSEMBLY HEARING ROOMS ON BOTH
DAYS. IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN
THE SUMMIT YOU CAN CONTACT THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE FOR MORE
INFORMATION. THIS SESSION
SCHEDULES IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
FEBRUARY FOURTH WE HAVE CHECK
IN SESSION WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY
FIFTH CHECK IN SESSION THURSDAY
FEBRUARY SIXTH FLOOR SESSION AT
NINE AM. MEMBERS WE WILL BE
STAYING HERE FOR THE FIRST
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY I ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR. WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS AGAIN WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY ASK THE
PLEASE TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF THE FLOOR OR TAKE YOUR
SEATS. THANK YOU. YEAH WE ASK
THAT THOSE IN THE GALLERY ALSO
PLEASE TAKE THEIR SEATS FOR THE
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU.
MISTER KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY
WE HONOR AN AMERICAN HERO.
FIRST LIEUTENANT RYAN MICHAEL
O'BRIEN A FAIR OAKS A DECORATED
WORLD WAR TWO VETERAN PASSED
AWAY ON NOVEMBER TWENTY FOURTH
AT THE AGE OF NINETY EIGHT.
FIRST ATTENDED A BRIAN HAD A
MONUMENTAL IMPACT ON OUR NATION
AND OUR COMMUNITY. AND HE HAD A
PERSONALITY TO MATCH IT. HIS
DEVOTION TO HIS COUNTRY WITH
EQUAL BY HIS WARMTH TOWARDS
OTHERS HIS SENSE OF HUMOR WAS
IS AN ALIVE INNING AS IS
PERSONAL STORY WAS INSPIRING. A
BELOVED AND TREASURED FIGURE IN
OUR LOCAL VETERANS COMMUNITY HE
WAS A TIRELESS LEADER AN
ADVOCATE FOR ALL WHO SERVED.
BORN IN LOS ANGELES ON MARCH
NINETEENTH NINETEEN TWENTY TWO.
FIRST LIEUTENANT O'BRIEN
GRADUATED FROM MOUNT CARMEL
HIGH SCHOOL. AFTER WORLD WAR
TWO BEGAN HE ENLISTED IN THE
UNITED STATES AIRFORCE. HE WAS
COMMISSIONED A SECOND
LIEUTENANT IN JUNE OF NINETEEN
FORTY FOUR FLYING IS B. TWENTY
FOUR OVER NOT A THIRTY
DANGEROUS AIR MISSIONS HE ALSO
ONLY EARNED THE RANK. OF FIRST
LIEUTENANT. ON HIS THIRTY FIFTH
MISSION. HIS TAIL GUNNER SHOT
DOWN AN ENEMY FIGHTER. BUT NOT
BEFORE DID FIRED MULTIPLE
TWENTY MILLONES MILLIMETER
SHELLS THAT HIT THE GAS TANK IN
HIS WING. AMAZINGLY THE SHELLS
FAILED TO EXPLODE SAVING HIS BE
TWENTY FOUR FROM BEING BLOWN
OUT OF THE SKY. THE SHELVES
HAVE BEEN SABOTAGED BY JEWS
WORKING IN OSKAR SCHINDLER'S
AMMUNITION FACTORY. AND EVENT
PORTRAYED IN THE NINETEEN
NINETY THREE MOVIE SCHINDLER'S
LIST. FIRST LIEUTENANT O'BRIEN
WAS AWARDED THE DISTINGUISHED
FLYING CROSS FOR AIR MEDALS THE
ORDER OF THE PURPLE HEART. AND
THE EUROPEAN AFRICAN MIDDLE
EASTERN METAL WITH THREE BATTLE
STARS. ON JULY TENTH TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN YOU RECEIVE
THE GOVERNMENT OF FRANCE'S
HIGHEST CIVILIAN HONOR IT'S A
LEGION OF HONOR MEDAL. HIS FOUR
HUNDRED. FOR A GROUP ALSO
AWARDED THE PRESIDENTIAL UNIT
CITATION FOR ITS PART IN THE
DESTRUCTION OF OIL REFINERIES
IN ROMANIA DEPRIVING GERMAN
TROOPS OF CRITICAL RESOURCES.
FIRST GENERAL BRIAN TO ROADS IN
BATTLE WE'RE JUST THE BEGINNING
OF HIS SERVICE. AS A RESIDENT
OF FAIR OAKS FOR OVER FOUR
DECADES HE FOUNDED AND SERVED
AS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE MASONS ASSOCIATION. AND
PARTICIPATED IN AMERICAN LEGION
POST THREE EIGHTY THREE. W. PO
SIX ONE FIVE EIGHT MILITARY
ORDER OF THE PURPLE HEART
CHAPTER THREE EIGHTY FIVE AS
WELL AS THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF
THE FRENCH LEGION. THE GREY
EAGLES AND THE NIGHTS OF
COLUMBUS. FIRST ATTENDED A
BRIAN TO SURVIVE BY HIS PADDY
AND OVER. AIRED ABROAD. COLLEEN
O'BRIEN SURELY HIS SON RYAN MY
BROWN JUNIOR. SEVENTEEN GRAND
CHILDREN OF GREAT. AND ONE
GREAT GREAT GRANDCHILD. LAST
YEAR I HAD THE CHANCE TO
RECOGNIZE FIRST LIEUTENANT
O'BRIEN ON THIS FLOOR AND
SENATOR JONES INTRODUCED HIM TO
OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE.
IT WASN'T THE FIRST TIME WE MET
AS I THE PLEASURE OF GETTING TO
KNOW HIM AND MANY LOCAL
pMOVING RECOGNITION DAY FOR
POW'S HAD EVERY YEAR IN A ROW.
I LEARNED FROM HIM SO MUCH
ABOUT SERVICE AND ABOUT HER
HISTORY AS WELL AS QUITE A FEW
IRISH JOKES AS WE BONDED OVER
OUR SHARED HERITAGE. ACCORDING
TO THE US DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS. OF THE
SIXTEEN MILLION AMERICANS WHO
SERVED IN WORLD WAR TWO. FEWER
THAN THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND. ARE STILL WITH US. WE
LOSE THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EVERY DAY. FOR THOSE OF US BORN
IN SUING GENDER GENERATIONS I
DON'T THINK ANY HISTORY BOOK.
OR DOCUMENTARY CAN EVER FULLY
CAPTURE THE COSMIC SIGNIFICANCE
OF THAT CONFLICT THE SHEER
SCALE OF. MOBILIZATION
INSTRUCTION HERE WAS A MAN
SACRIFICE TRAGEDY AND TRIUMPH
IN THE IMMEASURABLE STAKES. FOR
HUMANKIND. HEROES LIKE
LIEUTENANT O'BRIEN OUR OUR LAST
BEST SOURCE OF TRUE
UNDERSTANDING AND APPRECIATION
OUR LAST REMAINING LINK TO THIS
GREATEST GENERATION THE DEFINED
OUR NATIONAL CHARACTER IN THE
TWENTIETH CENTURY AND INTO THE
INDEFINITE FUTURE. THESE
INCOMPARABLE VETERANS REMAIN
THE MORAL ANCHOR OF OUR SOCIETY
ITS ENTER OF GRAVITY WE MUST
CHERISH EACH AND EVERY ONE OF
THEM WELL THERE WITH US AND
REMEMBER THEM. WITH ERNEST
ADMIRATION WHEN THEY'RE GONE.
RIGHT MICHAEL O'BRIEN WAS THE
BEST AMONG US AND HIS LEGACY
WILL LIVE ON AS LONG AS THE
STARS AND STRIPES WHY. MADAM
SPEAKER I ASK THE TODAY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER KILEY MISTER MATHIS
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THIS TO
GERMANY MEMORY THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. MEMBERS O'BRIEN WAS A
GOOD FRIEND OF MINE AND MY
WIFE'S WE- GOT TO KNOWN. OVER
MANY YEARS ADVOCATING FOR
VETERANS- I JUST REMEMBER- LAST
TIME I GOT TO SEE HIM WE WERE.
AT A VETERANS EVENT TALKING
POLICY AND- USE REMINDING NINE.
ME ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT SEARCH
WAS IN FAMILY WAS AND HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATION I KNOW HE'S
BEEN A STRONG MENTOR FOR MANY
AND- FROM ONE VETERAN TO
ANOTHER FALLEN BUT NOT
FORGOTTEN REST IN PEACE MY
FRIEND. THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS
WE WILL ALL REMEMBER HIS
SERVICE AND THANK YOU TO ALL
THE VETERANS HERE TODAY FOR
YOUR SERVICE. IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL BE
LIFTED AND WE WILL REMOVE TO
THE REMAINING ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY.
YEAH. CAN.
THANK YOU
MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
ARE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
MISLI MON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER IT IS WITH A
HEAVY HEART THAT I DURING IN
MEMORY OF DOCTOR MON WAY LET.
LOCUSTS MANUEL WAS BORN INTO A
FARMWORKERS FAMILY AND WAS A
LIFELONG RESIDENT OF OXNARD. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO HE BEGAN HIS
OPTOMETRY PRACTICE IN OXNARD
AND WAS THE FIRST SPANISH
SPEAKING DR IN THE AREA. MONEY
WELL SPENT OVER FIFTY FOUR
YEARS IN PUBLIC SERVICE HE WAS
ELECTED TO THE OXNARD CITY
COUNCIL IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. AND IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO BECAME THE FIRST ELECTED
LATINO MAYOR OF OXNARD. THE
LAST TWELVE YEARS HE SERVED AS
A COMMISSIONER FOR THE PORT OF
ONE OF FOR THE PORT OF WHINY.
SERVING UNTIL HIS DEATH. I
REMEMBER TALKING TO HIM IN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS IN HIS HOME.
WE CHATTED ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT
IT WAS TO HAVE REPRESENTATION
IN ELECTED OFFICE. WE CHATTED
ABOUT THE IDEA THAT POLITICAL
COURAGE IS NEEDED. AND WHAT IT
MEANT TO BE THE FIRST
REPRESENTATIVE AND LATINO
ELECTED INTO A SPECIFIC AREA. I
REMEMBER OUR CONVERSATIONS
FONDLY HE WAS A MAN. OF GREAT
PROMISE DID SO MUCH FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND FOR THAT WE ARE
SO GRTEFUL HE AND HIS WIFE
EVEN MY LAW OFFICE GRATION
GRACIOUSLY HOSTED MANY MANY
EVENTS IN THEIR BEAUTIFUL HOME
IN OXNARD ALWAYS IN SUPPORT OF
GOOD CAUSES FOR HIS BELOVED
CITY OF OXNARD. EVEN DURING
TIMES WHEN HIS DEATH WAS
DELICATE HE REMAINED A SHORT
MAN WITH MUCH HUMILITY.
ATTENTIVE TO HIS SURROUNDINGS
AND AWARE OF THE CURRENT NEWS.
DOCTOR LOPEZ. MANOLO OFFICE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE EVEN MY-
DAUGHTERS MIGHTY SIGNED TIFFANY
SISTER RUTH TORRES SON LAW FRED
MASSACRE. GRANDCHILDREN LAYLA
AND MANNY TWO STEP
GRANDCHILDREN EIGHT. TO STEP
CHRIS STEPDAUGHTERS EIGHT STEP
GRANDCHILDREN AND NINE STEP
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. DOCTOR
LOPEZ WILL BE MISS I ASK THAT
THE ASSEMBLY RESPECTFULLY
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER MOM MISTER
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THIS
A GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER. DR MANUAL M.
LOPEZ WAS HIGHLY REGARDED IN
THE COMMUNITY OF OXNARD AND THE
GREATER VENTURA COUNTY. MANNY
AS HE WAS KNOWN WAS A KIND AND
GENTLE LEADER WHO BUILT STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THOSE AROUND
THEM. HE WAS KNOWN AS SOMEONE
WHO ALWAYS WAS WILLING TO SERVE
AND SHARE HIS VISION HIS RECORD
OF. HIS RECORD OF SERVICE TO
THE COMMUNITY AS EXEMPLIFIED BY
THE MANY ROLES HE SERVED. IN
ADDITION TO HIS OPTOMETRY
BUSINESS AND MANY YEARS SERVING
ON THE OXNARD CITY COUNCIL AND
PORT HUENEME ME BOARD DOCTOR
LOPEZ WAS INVOLVED WITH MANY
CIVIC ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
THE OXNARD CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THE HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THE BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUB BOARD THE WOMEN'S LEGACY
FUND AND THE VENTURA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION. AMONG
MANY MANY OTHERS. HE HAS EARNED.
NUMEROUS AWARDS AND RECOGNITION
AND HIS PROFESSION AND
COMMUNITY. DOCTOR LOPEZ WAS A
GRADUATE OF INTER COLLEGE. UC
BERKELEY AND THE UC BERKELEY
SCHOOL OF OPTOMETRY I ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN AND IS MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR ONE MR WOULD YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
CHURN AND ASKED WE ADJOURN THE
MEMORY OF GEORGE OR TEASE A
CINEMA COUNTY LEADER WHO
ADVOCATED FOR MORE THAN FIFTY
YEARS TO EMPOWER THE LATINO
COMMUNITY AND IF BILL CULTURAL
PRIDE. GEORGE PASSED AWAY ON
JANUARY WENTY SECOND AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTY FIVE. HE ARRIVED
IN CINEMA COUNTY IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR TO BEGIN LIFE AS A
SOCIAL WORKER. FIRST FOR THE
COUNTY AND THEN FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FOR CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE HE SOON MET
COUNTY CATHOLIC MONTHS IN YOUR
GEORGE **** AND THEY WORK
TOGETHER TO DEVELOP THE LATINOS
UNIDOS SCHOLARSHIP- SO THE
STORY GOES A MONSIGNOR
RECEIVED. FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
FROM A GAMBLER AND THE USE THAT
MONEY TO GIVE FIVE ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS SCHOLARSHIPS THE FIRST
YEAR AND IT'S ONLY GROWN FROM
THERE. GEORGE COLLABORATED WITH
THREE OTHER COMMUNITY LEADERS
TO CREATE THE NORTH BAY HUMAN
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION WHICH
LATER BECAME THE CALIFORNIA
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATE HUMAN DEL
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION TO
ASSIST FARMWORKERS AND OTHERS
WHO STRUGGLE WITH POVERTY. AND
INJUSTICE. GEORGE SERVICES
FIRST CHIEF FROM NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN AND UNTIL HIS RETIREMENT
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR. I
GREW UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP TO BE
ONE OF CINEMA OUNTY'S LARGEST
NON PROFITS WITH ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED EMPLOYEES SERVING
TWENTY THOUSAND QUITE CUT
CLIENTS AND REVENUES TOPPING
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. TODAY IT STIRS TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THIRTY
ONE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES. GEORGE WAS BORN EAST
LOS ANGELES IN NINETEEN THIRTY
FOUR THE YOUNGEST OF SIX.
CHILDREN OF IMMIGRANTS WHO
WORKED AS IMAGE AS MIGRANT FARM
WORKERS HE WORK IN THE FIELDS
WHEN HE WAS YOUNG AND TALKS
ABOUT HE HOW HE WEIGHED ONLY
SEVENTY FIVE POUNDS. RECEIVED A
NICKEL FOR EVERY SIXTY FIVE
POUND SACK HE FILLED. HE SERVED
IN THE US ARMY AND LATER
RECEIVED A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
SOCIAL SCIENCE FOR FRESNO
STATE. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO
RECOGNIZE HIS MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS GEORGE RECEIVED
AN HONORARY DEGREE OF DOCTOR OF
HUMANE LETTERS FROM CINEMA
STATE UNIVERSITY. WE CENTER
SYMPATHIES TO HIS WIFE CAROL
HIS CHILDREN ROBERT AND DIANE
HIS TWO GRANDDAUGHTERS AND AS
MANY FRIENDS AND FELLOW
ADVOCATES. I ASKED WE ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF GEORGE R.
TEASE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER WOULD MEMBERS PLEASE
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DEATH TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. ALL REQUESTS FOR
JOURNEY MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TO RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MISLIM OWN MOVES AND
MISTER KILEY SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
THURSDAY FEBRUARY SIXTH AT NINE
AM.